a greek coast guard boat arrives in
corfu harbour on board is a passenger
rescued from the euro ferry olympia
which caught fire on friday
the 21 year old truck driver from
belarus told rescuers he'd heard the
voices of other passengers as he escaped
from his cabin to the upper deck of the
ferry he's now recovering in hospital
this morning we had very good news a 21
year old belarusian citizen came to our
hospital he was in very good shape he
underwent medical examinations he was
rehydrated and went through additional
tests
his rescue has renewed hopes that other
missing passengers may still be alive
this woman's come to the port hoping to
hear news about her husband
he's alive he's a professional he's very
experienced and capable and he's alive
i'm telling you with certainty action
has to be taken immediately how much
longer can all those people in there
bear it
these passengers were some of the first
to be rescued from the burning ferry
arriving home in italy they said they
were traumatized by what they'd
experienced
it wasn't easy i'm a strong person used
to fighting but this time the fear was
great
when you start to see the smoke and you
can't breathe anymore and people are
falling to the ground small children a
situation like that you can't understand
unless you've lived it
firefighters boarded the ferry for the
first time on sunday morning they'd been
delayed by temperatures of up to 600
degrees celsius
tugboats have now secured the vessel but
the authorities are worried whether
conditions may deteriorate further
hampering the rescue operation
victoria gatenby al jazeera